foreign
[Music]
but I don't get a chance to do a q a
with people like Dale Dickey and West
Studio very often so I am getting a
relationship
um
Max this is so this is your first
feature right yeah that's right
congratulations it's
thank you thank you it's freaking lovely
I've seen it multiple times now I love
it I recommend it to everybody to go see
it so you're the writer of the script
too do you want to talk about
um what inspired this story
I'll give it a go
um it's the most honest reasonable
question in the world and one that I
have yet to fit into a concise or
quotable
um sound bite but
um I guess that's not the point of of
this particular screening so
clearly because I still haven't even
started answering the question
um
I uh I I guess the best way I can try to
describe it is
you know that that's where I grew up in
Southwest Colorado that's my home
um it's where I live still
um
and it starts with that I suppose
feeling very grateful and blessed to
live in a place I find truly beautiful
um even though it can bewilder and
mystify and frustrate me I I love it and
sometimes maybe what I love is my
memories of it or maybe what I love is
my hopes for it but it's it's a love
um
anyways and
and I also I fell in love deeply in love
which makes you just want to talk about
that stupid four-letter word and um
and at the same time you know so many of
the people I knew who who'd raised me
I was kind of raised by The Village I
suppose and cared for me and whom I
cared for as well were
falling out of love in in the various
ways that life can
um
pull it from us through divorce or death
or any number of ways in the
contradiction I suppose of what I was
feeling and experiencing and what I was
and and the the challenges that I was
seeing
those I cared for feel sort of became
the the question at the heart of it and
what I found myself wanting to believe
is that love can
be
a deep and enriching part of our Lives
whether or not it's shared with another
person and um or if it's shared with
someone who isn't here anymore
um
and
yeah I guess you uh
Ponder those sorts of things
you idolize these actors as I had for so
long and and picture them
in this place
and spend enough hours driving around
and uh listening to stupid sad country
songs like
this is sort of what bubbles up out of
it
thank you for sharing that I love that
answer and thank you for your
um the emotion that you poured into the
film and
the emotion that you're bringing us
obviously tonight
um
so what uh
what made you think of these two were
were these people that you had in mind
from the start for the movie
yeah I you know before there was even a
script or an idea it begins probably
with Dale
at the very beginning just as as the
movie does and
I first really noticed her in Winter's
Bone and was couldn't stop thinking
about this actor who was
uh like unthinkably true whatever that
odd word really means but I felt like
this was someone I knew who was like
deep and strong and tender
and then
and and I was so moved by the image that
this this could be someone in this world
and like a hopeful version of this world
that I I want to show and
when you start picturing this this actor
in a world you're faced with the
challenge of asking who the hell could
could sit next to her
um
and it's not a very long list it might
in fact be a list only the person who
would take you out to the swamp to find
the dead body of your dad could do it
yeah wow
that's a reference from Winter's Bone
which uh
Dale probably doesn't toot her own horn
but she won a spirit award for that in
2010. yeah thank you
um and yeah and west west has been a
hero of mine for a long time
um you know just like looking for
what I've always wanted to do is show
tough places tenderly and these are two
actors who have played tough characters
tenderly and with Humanity for so so so
so so long and I'm just
really honored to be like a footnote in
this great thing that they've both built
um in their own ways
so for for the two of you
um
how did you build this
this relationship with people who
between you know I'm assuming they were
kind of
High School sweethearts and or they have
flirtation and spend a lot of time
together as kids
I think Dale can handle that one
thank you uh
[Laughter]
um
you know what uh Fey and lito share a
great amount of time in their childhood
in their high school years and whatever
that relationship was but they've had
about 40 years apart being married to
people another widowed both of their
Partners were
musicians and um
uh we we reconnect so Wes and I
decided we lived in a house together
because during the bubble we were all
secluded in different houses out on this
Farm farmland and
um so we just decided we're just going
to get along as people and not talk too
much about the character's relationship
because we wanted to be spontaneous and
you know we had the same sensibilities
same sense of humor so we instantly had
a chemistry and and and and as Wesley
said many times you don't stop having
those feelings just because you're older
so the butterflies still come and um it
just felt pretty real in that
relationship
I mean Max guided us brilliantly
um it was a beautiful script
your turn now dear absolutely well
essentially this is Max's story and I I
always thought to myself wow Max you're
a brave man uh this these these
characters that you're describing here
are going through it an extremely uh
rough time emotionally in their lives
and it's a uh almost a tearing way of
all the uh
defenses they've built up over the a
over the years to ward off the kinds of
pains that they've endured from the
losses that they've struggled through in
their lives and and in that way they
begin to uh
connect again as vulnerable human beings
but you know I'm at that point where I
would like to move if you don't mind
from our statements to the q a i i
because I've done a number of interviews
today and what
um
what uh what really interests me is what
what does the audience you know think of
it uh I mean we laid our stuff out there
now now it's your turn to tell us what
you what you want to know about it
you think so we we don't usually do
audience questions but I see there's a
burning desire right in the front so I
guess we'll take it
what was that
why did you leave why did Leto leave
yeah
yeah
yeah
dude
you asked for it Wes
you get the same old me
[Laughter]
uh no actually
I think it had a lot to do with
the services I mean the what
what uh Lito's function had to do with a
phase life I think he felt like was
completed and now it's more or less up
to Faith to make the next move
I I think that's why uh lito
said okay I've I've come here I I'm not
sure I can take it
emotionally
but I think I've done as much as I
possibly can and uh
now it's time to move up
did you have a question
so so many
um please ask I actually I I first
wanted to say you know I'm a fan of
going to theater a lot and your
performances and it just reminded me of
the greatest theater performances I've
seen which is and the and the toughest
jobs to do or when you have less words
and you still have to fill every moment
and I just
the way that you set up the blocking for
them
uh you know when he's telling her
that he's going to go and they have a
scene where they're on like on opposite
sides of the screen they just look like
so awkward like they're at a Junior High
dance and like shuffling with their feet
it's just it's it's so fantastic
um for Dale
how there's so many you know there's so
many
I was so glad that you got this role
because I've been so enjoying you for so
long and I was so glad that that you got
something you know that was so focused
on you but for you what is it like
having so many scenes where you are
where it's you
it's a little terrifying yeah
thank you for those kind words I uh I've
spent my entire career playing wonderful
supporting
uh
actors character actors popping in and
out and I've loved that I I like being
in the background so I've done a lot of
leads on in theater on stage but this
was my first opportunity on film and I
was I I was terrified I knew I saw the
script I loved the script I loved mex's
two short films I loved the letter he
wrote me and talking to him and I was
like when am I ever going to get an
opportunity like this I was scared it
was a huge challenge could I carry the
film could I achieve this with all the
quiet and it's been something I'd been
longing for to play Something Completely
against what I've always played and and
I as I said before I won the lottery
with this young man terrific director
terrific human being and then having Mr
Studio as my my partner to play off of
uh just made it easy
I'm very grateful for the opportunity
and I
Max how how do you how help someone
through solo long solo like long periods
of time with solo performance
um that's a good question I I don't know
I mean like the first thing I would have
to acknowledge is that just like being
my first rodeo and with such consummate
professionals felt there were real
limits to
how far I should go in in presuming to
instruct or explain anything to these
characters who are ultimately going to
share more to these actors who are
ultimately going to share more with the
characters than than I have yet to
um
so
you know I tried even though it
ultimately comes off as a version of
space and silence to to remember that
you know silence is never actually
silence it's just the sounds that we
don't normally hear and and Stillness is
not really Stillness it's just the
movements we we maybe don't normally
recognize we make and um
even in those those quiet and Placid
moments to remember that there's a story
here and there's a progression even if
routine itself is only a progression
um
and and on set I I don't know I tried to
sort of demonstrate my own affection for
the characters really and
um
uh help help to set that tone for lack
of a better word and and help put the
camera in the right space and then and
then just step back and and watch the
the things they did
my family had that Shasta by the way
uh
uh we crammed four people in there two
adults and two kids
this is pretty squished
um but this you know seeing that there's
so much in this movie that just reminds
me of you know camping as a kid like I
grew up in a really rural area too
then I also I have people in my family
like
your characters who they know every
plant in Southern Illinois where I'm
from they know every bird they know
they're part of the land almost and I'm
just wondering you know and then when
Dale tells that story about her dad and
the sheep and then seeing the Sheep
again
just wondering um if that was an
important part of this it almost feels
like
an environmental commentary without
being in over environmental commentary
the way that these people are connected
to the land
is that something that's personally
important to you in your life
you have um
of course and then for the the character
I mean if we're dealing with a story
about connection or the lack of a
connection I think it's also a story
about a character finding Connections in
the in the things that are there and
find finding worlds in in like the small
places that she's able to move through
and um
like it could be described as a one
location movie but at the same time like
we shot over a month and leaves went
from green to Yellow to not being there
at all and the character's relationship
to the surroundings and the beauty she
finds in it transforms completely and I
like think of it as many different
worlds
um in that place but you know like Dale
you showed up and you had a book on
stars and
um birds and I have a big old bag of
books on things laughs
and it's like you know we're all from
different places west west from Oklahoma
lives in Santa Fe they'll grow up in
uh mountains of Tennessee I grew up in
Southwest Colorado like these are
different places but I think they share
certain things which
um I don't know I maybe helps like
explain why I felt such a closeness
yeah something feels Universal about
that part of it it feels like it could
be a lot of places in the United States
I'd like to believe that any place shown
like with an effort at specificity and
Truth like somehow becomes Universal and
vast that's
um what so was there one particular
performance of of Wes's that you that
struck you that made you want to want
him in this
the same way kind of Dale
freaked me out in
um Winner's bone the last Mohicans is
Unforgettable but then like hostiles
much more recently I'm also just like a
huge fan of the reservation dogs
character that was not during shooting
but worth a shout out absolutely
phenomenal show
um
talk about the um I don't want to say
the background character but you're
still supporting characters who end up
being very important in sort of peopling
this world but who are also kind of
quirky uh where did you get the idea for
the lesbian couple the the family with
the four sons and the daughter and nope
here
the dead dad
I don't know I my life out there has
always been made richer by the
picks and tricks and oddballs who wind
up washed up in odd places and in the
right moments can be like cherished and
and loved there and I liked the idea of
a of a campsite strange enough that
nobody there is going to share
everything but everyone's going to share
a little something
um I don't know I've always seen people
you may not expect in um
these these sorts of spots
it's also like those are just my friends
like Randy's heroes are her brothers
um or all the cowhands who I grew up
with and that little girl's local girl
um it's nice to nice to throw your
buddies into something when you can
appropriate enough too I hope
Julia really deliver mail on a horse to
campsites in Colorado
that's more of an Arizona thing
but I hope we can forgive that that
would be awesome I got I gotta say and
I've said this before I I don't think
Max I think I'm correct in the first
script I read of yours the mailman was
not in there and I was so thrilled when
he wrote that character because it was
right around the same time that
I don't want to get political but there
was an idiot put in charge of the United
States Post Office named
de Joyce
and it was like this is an institution
people depend on their Mayo people wait
on that letter my dad's 95 and he wants
a letter in the mail not a phone call
and uh they'll you know rain wind
whatever they get there and I love that
homage to the United States Post Office
uh so one of my my favorite Parts is the
song that you do together are are the
two of you singers and musicians
[Laughter]
because you sounded good to me
I I I I grew up singing I did a lot of
musical theater I love to sing but I I
kind of quit singing after a while and I
I barely play guitar
Wes is quite an accomplished guitar
musician we work together
Dale has a great voice and she can carry
a tune much better than I can I see you
we can testify to that when we try to go
kind of high at the end of the song
see I knew it
should also be noted that that's that's
your guitar West like the It Was Written
of course to be a beat up acoustic and
then he shows up with a bright red
electric guitar there was no
there was no going back from there
and tiny little speakers
I was alive
just rolled the camera and we just did
all warts and all
I did yeah I mean I think what I loved
about it is that you're not rock stars
and I just love seeing people hearing
people sing with their natural voices in
movies you know what I mean like it's so
much more touching
and real
well Wes had to pretend to be a lot
worse at Guitar than he actually is
could you shred were you like we all
when the camera was off you're shredding
yeah
all wanted to be real rock stars you
know that that's really where it comes
from
[Laughter]
uh do we have any other burden desires
from the audience before we go
anybody yeah
the question was how did you capture
such great sound
um we had a uh one one sound person on
set a very strong yeah small crew Sean
uh beloved dedicated neurotic as are all
great sound people who
made his business to get to everything
as cleanly as possible
um you know I think I share with them My
Philosophy like what silence actually is
and it's an opportunity to hear
hear so many things and then um
worked with a great sound editor and
designer in Mexico named javieres who
um brought a lot of it to light and like
the truth is a lot of that is is
re-recorded in Mexico which is
like causing the question like funny
concepts of what's real like if you
heard what you record on location it
doesn't sound real and if you hear like
keychains in a studio you know that does
sound real that's just what we've been
taught to expect from films and there's
some some battles you can fight in some
that you can't
but we worked really hard on on trying
to fill the world and make it feel
robust
um through what you hear so I'm happy to
hear that
speaking of shooting I've heard several
times that it's actually very hard to
shoot in in daylight like that in a
movie that's in mostly daylight is that
actually true
yeah there's this the uh like kind of
conventional wisdom says that soft light
is better and it's best to shoot before
the sun is too high or after it's begun
setting and that is beautiful and we we
chase that whenever we could but I don't
know I this great cinematographer I work
with Alfonso redo Salcedo and I you know
through doing short films out there and
working on film which this is discovered
that like the the Celluloid allowed us
to use to to shoot right through the
middle of the day and right in the
really hard light and
I mean that's like what that is and and
we we love the way it looks
um
so
yeah I I I find that midday Sun really
really beautiful Wes I think I
interrupted your comment did you have a
comment you learn to say about the look
of the film or the sound of the film
I was going to say we did no looping
whatsoever
I don't think so
usually after covet looping's been done
in like people's closets which is so
strange but no I didn't have to do any
for this God
anybody else have a question yeah
favorite scene favorite scene what is
your favorite scene oh I know you're
gonna make me go first
it's I I can't make decisions I'm
there's a lot but I I I think I have to
say the final night of filming when I
climbed out we all climbed that mountain
was a glorious rap night experience and
a you know waiter
reach the penultimate and let it go and
uh is it just a beautiful night you know
I'm twice as old as all these young kids
and I was like bring an oxygen tank okay
it's 12 000 feet and I'm still smoking
so yeah
but I grew up hiking I love the
mountains and I knew maybe Dale couldn't
accomplish this but face certainly could
so that adrenaline kicks in and they all
were there to support me and it was a
a glorious way to say goodbye to a
beautiful family
my favorite scene was uh the one where
we're sitting on the
very near the water on the rocks and and
I asked her Faye to take a picture and
she initially says no no I don't want to
take a picture and then finally
acquiesces too
being directed
to show me what to do yeah exactly
okay and and right and so she makes a
slow turn like that and uh and then that
picture becomes a uh a real
yeah I I enjoyed directing her
and I enjoyed your direction I was gonna
say that was the best scene in the movie
it was so tight in every way
um well thank you so much to all of you
for coming congratulations on this movie
it's fantastic it opens Friday
tomorrow opens tomorrow
um opens tomorrow tell family and
friends go see it again thank you guys
for coming thank you so much really
appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]